made a nice story you fixing up that old
keep lifting the curse must've told it a
hundred times but something got to gnaw
at me thinking the spirits there weren't
really at rest but maybe the gods
weren't finished with us
[Music]
[Music]
I used to drink oh my god came out
you forgive us
that's the trouble the dreams
sooner or later
we all have to wake up
[Music]
hi everybody four years ago we launched
our first crowdfunding campaign and
together with your help we made the
fantasy role-playing game pillars of
eternity one of the highest rated
crowdfunding games of all time we're
really thankful for all your
contributions along the way not only
your pledges but you're passionate
feedback that shaped the game in the
world
we really loved working alongside the
community from the very beginning and we
want to include you again in the process
it just wouldn't be the same otherwise
I'm happy announced that the same
talented and passionate team has been
working on the sequel to pillars of
eternity for over the last year now
every dollar pledge you're invested
during the campaign is going to allow me
to give the team more time and resources
to make the best game possible for you
they're really excited to show you what
they've been up to so welcome to death
fire
[Music]
[Applause]
pillars of eternity too is our attempt
to continue building on all the stuff
that we did in pillars of eternity one
we really wanted to focus on the things
that made the Infinity engine games
great which are exploration of beautiful
environments the real time with paws
tactical combat system and a really rich
and engrossing story that has companions
that react to the choices that you make
in addition to some of the new
companions that we're introducing we're
also bringing back some of our old
companions from pillars one one of these
will be a dare players will get to
experience how he's changed and see what
his story is after the time that passes
between the two games at the beginning
of pillars of eternity - you are still
the watcher of Kade Noah this figure
from the first game who can see into the
spirit world
and here the Lord of this castle and at
the beginning of pillars to the god
áthis who is presumed to be dead
occupies the statue underneath the
castle of CAD Noah animates it and tears
his way out it destroys the castle it
kills most the people in the castle and
leaves you at the brink of death it's
bad enough that he winds up almost
killing you but it turns out that your
life is linked to finding Athas and
figuring out what he's doing we're also
very excited about some of the choice
and consequence that we'll be
introducing the story in Dead Fire will
change both in response to the player's
actions in this game and also in
response to some of the decisions that
the player made in the Deerwood back in
pillars one pillars two features a
complete overhaul of not only the
graphics but many systems as well
including AI pathfinding and animation
our goal is to have a living world and
increase the active elements in the
scenes first we have a new weather
system that will change throughout the
day rain storms will pass through the
areas so cloth and trees will sway in
the wind and townspeople will react by
covering their heads or even heading
indoors
for the level design team a goal for
pillars of eternity too is to have the
world feel more alive and real you'll
find it villagers and commoners they
have daily routines they'll go to work
they'll come home they'll even go to the
tavern to have a drink secondly we have
a new AI back-end that will make our
NPCs and monsters smarter and tougher in
combat encounters will be more dynamic
and combat scenarios more tactically
challenging really really excited about
the new streaming system all of our
interior areas will stream in with
little to no loading providing a much
better play experience than the first
game we're pushing the boundaries of
what the previous engine was capable of
the our team is very excited to be using
the rendering techniques and technology
they'll showcase level of detail never
before seen in a game like this we
learned a lot of lessons in making the
first game and we got a lot of great
feedback from our fans we learned a lot
about how to use the technology that we
have been sort of developing over the
course of the game and really we just
want to leverage all that knowledge and
all that passion to make an even greater
experience we have one of the most
talented amazing teams here at obsidian
that has been very eager to show you
what they've been up to we will continue
with regular updates through the
crowdfunding campaign with more in depth
details about gameplay features dead
fire lore and new companions and pillars
of eternity - during this campaign you
the opportunity to invest and be part
the success of dead fire from everyone
here at obsidian we really want to thank
you for your support
[Music]